à à toutes et à tous nous propose que
nous débutions notre réunion de
commission
ce matin
auditionnons monsieur françois braun qui
est ministre de la santé et de la
prévention sur le projet de loi
relatif au dispositif de veille et de
sécurité sanitaire en matière de lutte
contre la copie de 19 je vous indique
que ce soit enfin plutôt que le texte a
été voté par l'assemblée nationale dans
la nuit il a cependant été amputé de
deux de ses articles relatifs à à la
possibilité de rétablir un pas sony
terre pour les déplacements entre la
france et l'étranger ou pour le
déplacement vers la corse ou l'outre-mer
monsieur le ministre vous nous direz
quelle conclusion si le gouvernement
dans la perspective de la discussion qui
aura lieu donc au sénat la semaine
prochaine
monsieur philippe bas et le rapporteur
de notre commission le texte viendra en
commission pour le coup mardi prochain à
9h je le dis pour l'ensemble des
collègues et mercredi prochain en séance
publique à 16h30
voilà je voudrais sa parole tout de
suite monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
avant d'en venir plus concrètement au
sujet qui nous occupe et pour ma
première intervention auprès de la
chambre haute du parlement
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire part
de mon honneur de me trouver ici pour
vous présenter le premier projet de loi
que le nouveau gouvernement soumet à
l'examen du parlement
je suis sincèrement attaché au
bicamérisme qui doit permettre un texte
un travail législatif de qualité c'est
pourquoi je me réjouis de pouvoir
travailler avec vous dans le respect des
convictions de chacune et de chacun je
le redis le bicamérisme c'est le respect
des deux chambres
l'assemblée nationale bien sûr qu'ils
semblent expérimenté des accords
politiques qui peuvent interpeller et le
sénat que je ne connais pas mais que je
connais comme une chambre à l'écouté des
territoires et soucieuse de la qualité
du droit sachant prendre ses
responsabilités
la première ministre a mis en avant lors
de sa déclaration de politique générale
dans votre hémicycle la nécessité de
bâtir des compromis sans se renier c'est
précisément dans cet état d'esprit que
je me présente à vous je le dis d'autant
plus qu'en matière de projets de loi
relatifs à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire le sénat en particulier votre
commission a été un acteur essentiel
dans la recherche et la teinte des
compromis équilibre nécessaire
je veux en particulier saluer ici le
rapporteur philippe bas pour ses
précieuses apport sur ces textes je
souhaite aussi rendre hommage aux
sénatrices et sénateurs mobilisé de
nombreuses heures en commission et dans
l'hémicycle pour examiner les
dispositions législatives de la gestion
de crise tout comme aux membres du
gouvernement avec qui vous avez
travaillé
la crise sanitaire a été une épreuve qui
a impliqué une part très significative
des ressources de la nation je veux
rendre hommage à toutes les personnes
mobilisées des personnels soignants aux
travailleurs des deuxième et troisième
ligne en passant par les agents du
ministère et les associations
permettez moi aussi d'avoir une pensée
particulière pour les personnes décédées
de la maladie à leurs proches
le projet de loi que je vous présente
acte l'extinction au 31 juillet prochain
du régime juridique de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et du régime de sortie de
crise sanitaire conformément à
l'engagement du gouvernement
il maintient toutefois certains outils
ciblées de gestion indispensables à ce
stade de l'épidémie en effet l'épidémie
est toujours là comme je les dis lors de
l'examen du projet de loi à l'assemblée
nationale
je dois aux françaises et aux français
comme à leurs représentants cinq
engagements en la matière
transparence quant à la situation
sanitaire que nous connaissons
protection de la population par
l'adoption de mesures nécessaires pour
limiter autant que faire se peut la
diffusion du virus
proportionnalité des mesures adoptées
pour que nos concitoyens puissent mener
une vie aussi normale que possible
préservation du système de santé pour
éviter le risque de saturation a
fortiori dans le contexte que nous
connaissons et qui justifie pleinement
mon engagement aux côtés des
professionnels pour l'accès aux soins
des français et maintien de la prise en
charge des soins orco vide c'est une
exigence d'équité vis-à-vis de tous nos
concitoyens
je voudrais donc avant d'en venir au
contenu du projet de loi commencer par
vous présenter la situation épidémique
et la stratégie du gouvernement pour y
faire face comme vous le savez nous
connaissons actuellement une septième
vague de l'épidémie de curry de
19,7 septième vague et duos ou variant
au micron b à 4 pb à 5 nous ne sommes
pas un cas unique car nos voisins
européens connaissent un tel rebond même
si la temporalité n'est pas exactement
la même au 12 juillet le taux
d'incidence atteint désormais 1344 pour
100000 habitants ce qui représente une
augmentation de 10 9% sur les sept
derniers jours cent trente mille cas par
jour sur ses sept derniers jours sont
recensés
l'ensemble du territoire français est
touché particulièrement les régions de
l'ouest et du sud du pays
concernant l'outre-mer et ses
territoires pour lesquels j'aurai
toujours une attention particulière la
situation est la suivante la guadeloupe
et dans une moindre mesure la guyane et
la réunion font face à une résurgence
épidémique mais selon une cinétique plus
lente qu'en métropole
la martinique a connu également une
telle résurgence la situation s'améliore
désormais grâce en particulier à
l'engagement de la population et à la
mobilisation des soignants auquel je
veux encore une fois rendre hommage à
mayotte à l'heure où je vous parle le
taux d'incidence est faible et la
situation maîtriser
l'épidémie met à l'épreuve notre système
de soins et en particulier l'hôpital
ma mission en tant que ministre chargé
de la santé et de lui permettre de faire
face
pour que nos hôpitaux sont en mesure de
faire face j'ai signé en fin de semaine
dernière une instruction à destination
des ars pour préciser les modalités de
mise en oeuvre des mesures d'urgence de
la mission que j'avais réalisé sur la
demande de ma prédécesseure madame
bourguignon
donner des leviers nouveaux territoires
engagés ensemble soigner soignant est
élu voici la méthode en laquelle je
crois
face au virus pour protéger les français
pour protéger notre système de soins
notre stratégie est claire je la résume
ray en cinq mots prévenir vacciner
tester isolé traité prévenir la
propagation du virus par les gestes
barrière
j'appelle à la responsabilité citoyenne
les gestes barrière doivent redevenir
des réflexes en particulier le port du
masque dans les lieux bondés ou les
transports en commun
certains souhaitent que nous rendions
juridiquement le port du masque
obligatoire mais face à des reports
épidémique successifs je privilégie la
responsabilité
vacciner pour protéger la vaccination
est notre arme de protection massive et
le médecin que je suis s'insurgera
toujours face au discours de
désinformation sur le vaccin
oui le vaccin réduit significativement
le risque de développer une forme grave
de covile 19
conformément aux recommandations des
autorités scientifiques
nous avons ouvert le deuxième rappel
vaccinal aux personnes vulnérables face
au virus notamment les plus de 60 ans et
les personnes immunodéprimées
d'après les derniers chiffres 3 7
millions de nos concitoyens éligibles
ont reçu la deuxième dose de rappel
c'est beaucoup plus qu'il ya quelques
jours nous devons encore accéléré je
vais mobiliser tous les moyens pour cela
testé et isolée en cas de doute quand
nous sommes qu'à contacter ou
symptomatique nous devons réduire les
contacts nous tester et si le test est
positif nous isoler jusqu'à
rétablissement
avec 3.4 millions de tests chaque
semaine les français ce test massivement
et ils ont raison traité pour limiter le
risque il existe des traitements
curatifs comme le pacs le vide ils
permettent pour les malades de l'aco
vide de réduire les risques de
développer une forme grave de la maladie
il ya également les traitements vous le
savez par anticorps monoclonaux les
français doivent connaître ses
traitements et pouvoir en parler à leurs
médecins et pharmaciens
l'épidémie est toujours là nous avons
donc besoin comme je le disais au début
de mon propos de certains outils
élémentaires de gestion et en
particulier d'outils de surveillance
épidémiologique et de lutte contre
l'apparition des nouveaux variants c'est
l'objet du présent projet de loi qui
comme vous le savez a été profondément
modifié par l'assemblée nationale
son article premier maintient jusqu'au
31 janvier 2023 les systèmes
d'information si depp et contacts qu
vide ils sont nos thermomètres de
l'épidémie ils sont donc essentielles
pour que nous puissions suivre
l'épidémiologie et protéger les français
grâce à cidep nous pouvons enregistrer
les tests que vides et prendre en charge
chaque personne positive nous pouvons en
outre généré les certificats pour que
nos concitoyens puissent se déplacer
dans les pays qui ont des restrictions
sanitaires à l'entrée de leur territoire
grâce à contacter le vide nous pouvons
identifier les cas contactez les
informer et les protéger c'est
dispositif s'accompagne de garanties en
matière de protection des données et de
confidentialité
je sais que votre commission qui a joué
un rôle important dans la création par
la loi de la cnil en 1978 et attentive
toute personne qui a accès au système
d'information est ainsi soumise au
secret médical ces dispositifs sont en
outre contrôler par la cnil et par le
comité de liaison parlementaires prévues
par la loi du 11 mai 2020 s'agissant de
cidep les tests négatifs sont supprimés
au bout de 3 mois 6 mois pour les tests
positifs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme vous le savez hier les députés ont
fait le choix contre l'avis du
gouvernement de supprimer le deuxième
article de ce projet de loi cet article
visait à maintenir jusqu'au 31 janvier
2023 la possibilité de demander certains
justificatifs aux personnes qui se
déplacent depuis ou vers le territoire
hexagonal la corse et les collectivités
d'outre-mer ces dispositions visaient
d'une part nous protéger d'un variant
inquiétant qui pourrait émerger à
l'étranger et d'autre part à protéger si
cela était nécessaire
et après consultation des exécutifs
locaux la corse et nos territoires
ultramarins dans les systèmes
hospitaliers peuvent être rapidement
saturés
je suis convaincu de la nécessité du
maintien de cette possibilité de
contrôles aux frontières que le conseil
scientifique et comme le conseil d'état
avait estimé proportionnée et je suis
prêt à en échange est largement avec
vous
j'en appelle donc à la responsabilité
collective nos territoires ont besoin de
cet outil
la possibilité d'exiger un pass
sanitaires ou vaccinale pour accéder à
des lieux de vie courante tombera le 31
juillet ce texte est clair il n'y a pas
de place pour de fausses informations
sur les bancs des deux chemins
le parcours parlementaire de ce texte
n'est pas terminée le gouvernement
s'engagera pleinement au sénat pour
défendre l'importance de ces
dispositions et les rétablir
c'est donc dans cet état d'esprit que je
suis à votre disposition pour répondre à
vos questions je vous remercie
merci monsieur venu nous allons engager
la discussion générale mais
préalablement je vais dès la parole
monsieur philippe bas notre rapporteur
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
comme le fait un instant notre président
françois noël buffet
d'avoir bien voulu
accepter cette audition alors que la
nuit à semble-t-il été longue et je vous
remercie aussi des propos que vous avez
tenus avec beaucoup de courtoisie à
l'égard du sénat est d'ailleurs aussi
pour moi-même
sur le ministre e
j'ai une première question très pratique
à vous poser j'ai remarqué
que dans le métro non seulement tout le
monde ne porte pas de masque
mais que de plus en plus de voyageurs
n'en porte pas sans doute à cause de la
chaleur je voudrais savoir
si les autorités sanitaires dans toutes
les villes où des
métros mais aussi un circuit d'autobus
on mesure exactement la situation jour
après jour
et on vérifie
que les
recommandations sanitaires car il ne
s'agit que de recommandations sont
suffisamment respectée faute de quoi
et c'est la deuxième question je
voudrais vous poser
si l'on devait constater que
les risques de contamination sont
extrêmement graves dans ces lieux de
grande promiscuité que sont les
transports en commun
le gouvernement
est il prêt à proposer un amendement
pour que le parlement lui donne le
pouvoir pendant une durée limitée
d'imposer le port du masque dans ses
moyens de transport où l'épidémie semble
se propager extrêmement rapidement j'ai
entendu l'appel à la confiance et à vrai
dire nous le partageons depuis longtemps
et nous avions nous-mêmes
formuler une exigence de confiance à
l'égard de nos concitoyens sans laquelle
les mesures sanitaires ne peuvent pas
avoir d' efficacité
mais la protection individuelle qui est
réalisée quand on s'en remet
à l'esprit de responsabilité de chaque
citoyen a bien sûr ses limites et vous
êtes en charge de la santé publique et
je pense que cette question mérite à
tout le moins d'être posée
alors j'ai une deuxième question elle
est plus circonstancielle
il y a eu ce vote de l'assemblée
nationale
elle a pris ses responsabilités
c'est l'assemblée nationale le sénat
prendra les siennes sans accepter
d'ailleurs de pression de qui que ce
soit d'où qu'elles viennent quelle que
soit la nature
le respect du parlement
passe par la reconnaissance de son droit
d'avoir une opinion différente de celle
du gouvernement
mais je voudrais pour bien prendre la
mesure des choses
alors que vous savez comme nous le
savons qu'il sera difficile de faire
changer d'avis l'assemblée nationale je
voudrais savoir ce qui se passera si
invariants dangereux très dangereux
apparaît dans tel ou tel pays et que
vous ne disposez pas des moyens que vous
donne l'article 2 et en particulier je
voudrais savoir s'il est possible en
droit d'empêcher
les avions en provenance de certains
pays d'atterrir sans la disposition de
l'article 2 qui a été supprimée par
l'assemblée nationale et je voudrai
savoir si il est possible de mettre en
quarantaine à défaut d'avoir interdit
les vols en provenance de ces pays
plutôt l'atterrissage des avions en
provenance de ces pays s'il est possible
de mettre en quarantaine les voyageurs
en provenance de ces pays parce que vous
comprendrez que
raisonner en termes de tout ou rien et
est toujours un peu excessif et que s'il
ya des moyens alternatifs susceptibles
d'être mobilisés dans l'attenté
éventuelle
plutôt dans la tente d'un éventuel
projet de doigts qui serait discutée en
urgence ou souvenez peut-être que la loi
du 23 mars 2020 a été discutée et
adoptée en trois jours donc le parlement
est capable de réagir à l'urgence bien
sûr mais en dehors de cette législation
d'urgence qui pourrait être prise
dans l'hypothèse
où
intel variant apparaîtrait dans tel ou
tel pays
je voudrais savoir quelles sont les
mesures d'urgence au fond j'en ai cité 2
qui pourrait être appliquée
enfin
puisqu'on ne raisonne pas en terme de
tout ou rien
est ce qu'il y a de votre point de vue
une alternative à l'article 2 qui
pourrait être rédigé d'un commun accord
entre le gouvernement et le parlement
je pense que c'est ça être constructif
ce n'est pas vouloir forcer le passage
et
se draper dans une posture de
dramatisation en disant
devant tous les français que l'heure est
grave
nous avons connu je crois quelques
heures beaucoup plus grave que celle ci
merci
[Musique]
la parole monsieur le ministre dans
quelques instants
c'est ça ma parole
oui monsieur le sénateur
veut fait la remarque des transports en
commun titre personnel je me permets de
vous rapporter que j'ai constaté
n'inverse depuis une semaine prenant
régulièrement le train aux grandes
lignes j'ai pris alors effectivement
j'ai moins l'habitude de vous que le
métro mais en tout cas dans les gares
j'ai pu constater vraiment que plus de
nos concitoyens mais thème était le
masque mais
notre surveillance elle est basée sur le
suivi épidémiologique vous le savez
c'est à dire le nombre de cas par jour
nous n'avons pas actuellement un système
de surveillance qui contrait le
pourcentage de nos concitoyens qui porte
le masque qui ne porte pas le masque
dans l'est dans les transports en commun
mais je retiens cela comme une
possibilité
toutefois le suivi épidémiologique nous
permet de savoir si on a une envolée de
nouveau des contaminations ou pas avec
et vous le savez aussi ce délai toujours
entre cette envolée dépôt tamis nation
et la saturation des hôpitaux des délais
trop courts mais j'y reviendrai
donc pour l'instant en tout cas le texte
nous permet jusqu'au 1er août c'est à
dire dans les quinze jours qui viennent
d'avoir cette cette possibilité de
maintenir cette possibilité puisque le
texte maintient des tas de sortie
d'urgence sanitaire
nous sommes
hawx imiter du pic on peut constater une
légère diminution de l'augmentation
alors sans vouloir être trop optimistes
et sans vouloir dire on peut de nouveau
faire comme si de rien n'était en tout
cas les signaux commence à être moins
négatifs
en ce sens c'est grâce à cette
surveillance épidémiologique donc grâce
à ce thermomètre dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui est mis en avant par article
1 que nous avons aussi la possibilité de
suivre ce qui se passe
la suppression de l'article 2
alors je vous rassure n'est pas dans mon
caractère de faire des pressions mais
par contre d'essayer de convaincre par
des arguments et si possible des
arguments des arguments médicaux
cet article l'intérêt c'était
effectivement et et vous le dit
l'émergence d'un variant dangereux et
nous donner une capacité de réaction
rapide à l'émergence de ce variant
bien sûr je ne vais pas vous raconter
ici que ce contrôle aux frontières
arrêterait totalement la circulation
d'un virus l'expérience de sites de
cette épidémie de cette pandémie nous
enseigne l'humilité l'humidité contre
nos capacités et l'humidité quant à
l'évolution de ce virus et au sein de la
population mais quand même et on a pu
très bien le constater pendant la
première vague ce qu'il faut face à
cette résurgence épidémique possible
je ne dis pas probable se dit possible
plus le virus circule vous le savez plus
il mute et plus il mute plus il ya de
risques on arrive à une mutation
préoccupante
donc ce qui nous ce qui nous manque
toujours dans la réaction c'est d'avoir
du temps on l'a très bien constaté
pendant la première vague si je peux me
permettre un petit retour vers 7 vers
cette période que j'ai connus vraiment
de près souvenez-vous le cluster en
alsace qui est parti de mulhouse
strasbourg qui arrivait à la moselle qui
arrivait à metz nous n'avons pas eu le
temps de nous préparer ça a été
extrêmement brutal par contre
le reste de la france a eu le temps de
se préparer et a donc eu un impact et
notre système de santé a eu un impact
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins important
c'est en ce sens qu'il rédigeait
l'article 2 c'est à dire nous donner les
moyens d'agir tout de suite pour gagner
du temps du temps qui nous permet
d'anticiper un peu et de préparer notre
système de santé ne plus avoir cette
possibilité
c'est à coup sûr perdre du temps même si
et vous l'avez relever les chambres se
réunissent très vite prennent des
décisions très vite mais une journée
c'est un nombre de cas important
aujourd'hui une journée c 130 mille cas
en cas de résurgence épidémique majeur
ce sera beaucoup plus et donc derrière
une mise en danger de la de nos
concitoyens alors sur le sur le
juridique vous m'avez parlé vous allez
demander quel était d autres
possibilités
la première ministre
un des pouvoirs propres si nécessaire
pour obliger le port du masque à compter
du 1er août cela reste possible sur le
port du voile c'est un pouvoir de police
générale de la première ministre mais et
vous l'avez bien compris je mise nous
misons sur la responsabilité nous nous
devons apprendre à vivre avec ce virus
il y aura d'autres vagues n'est
peut-être pas nécessaire de légiférer à
chaque fois c'est probablement même trop
lourd je pense qu'aussi ses chambres
beaucoup d'activités donc c'est quelque
part nous donner un outil de continuer à
vivre avec ce virus
concernant la question de la quarantaine
et la possibilité de mettre des
personnes venant d'autres pays en
quarantaine
juridiquement c'est possible vous le
savez avec l'article 31 31-1 du code de
la santé publique
mais
le filtrage est relativement peu
efficace parce que il y aura déjà des
gens sur notre territoire et les volumes
risque d'être particulièrement important
dans une période où nous aurons besoin
de toutes nos ressources aussi pour nous
réorganiser en termes de système de
santé donc oui c'est possible je leur ai
dit l'importance pour moi est de réussir
à gagner du temps pour notre système de
santé
je suis désolé de l'analogique est
peut-être un peu triviale mais j'ai un
peu l'impression que sans cet article 2
en cas de résurgence
épidémique avec un variant
particulièrement des temps on nous
demande de sauter de l'avion sans
parachute mais en nous disant vous
inquiétez pas on va vous en a porté un
très vite avant vous écrasée au sol
j'avoue je préférerais sauté de l'avion
avec un parachute
merci monsieur le vice alors j'ai des
demandes de parole
monsieur loïc hervé qui doit être trop
visioconférence puis madame esther
benbassa puis madame marie mercier pour
l'instant monsieur le comte j'ai noté
mme chervet oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre tout
d'abord nos commandes ne pas partager
votre voeu de la responsabilité que vous
venez de faire un instant mais il faut
pas seulement l'évoqué pour le le port
du masque il faut le le porter beaucoup
plus dans le discours ça n'a pas été
assez fait ces dernières années et je ne
peux que vous rejoindre sur cette idée
de remettre la responsabilité
individuelle et collective au coeur de
la gestion de cette énième vague de
colis tout d'abord monsieur le ministre
si les systèmes d'information sidéré
contactez vite sont maintenus
temporairement à l'échelle du texte je
rappelle ici que de tels systèmes
d'information devra un jour disparaître
et le plus tôt sera le mieux
c'est ainsi que notre sensibilité sur
les questions de données personnelles
doivent doit s'exprimer et vous avez à
plusieurs reprises évoqué les les
fausses informations
et si vous voulez vraiment leur tendre
le cou crois qu'il faut être très clair
sur les mesures qui ont été abandonnées
d'un nouveau projet de loi faut être
transparent sur le bilan de ces mesures
françois en particulier aux passes sous
toutes ses formes mais je pense aussi à
l'application tout senti que vides dont
l'utilité d'être des quasi marginales
par la cnil
dans son rapport qu'elle a publié la
semaine dernière que n'ai-je entendu ici
au sénat quand cette mesure a été votée
j'en viens une question très sensible
monsieur me disent que vous n'avez pas à
porter qui est celle des soignants qui
ne sont pas à jour de leurs obligations
vaccinales par pas de selon expérience
suspendu j'élargis la question là aussi
monsieur nellis la transparence la plus
totale s'impose
combien sont ils à être suspendu on
parle de 15000 combien sont ils à être
interdits d'exercer à être en arrêt
maladie en disponibilité en congé quelle
est la conséquence de l'ensemble de ces
soignants sur le système de santé
français alors que beaucoup d'états qui
nous entourent je suis en régions
frontalières avec la suisse c est a
enlevé depuis longtemps ses obligations
quand vise quand envisagez vous de le
faire là aussi le sionisme le plus tôt
sera lié
merci merci monsieur hervé madame est
servie mbassa
merci monsieur le président un merci
monsieur le ministre votre
présentation
moi je voudrais poser quelques questions
d'abord sur le filtrage des urgences
pourriez vous nous expliquer quels en
sont les contours en pleine période de
recrudescence du coc vide est-ce
judicieux et vous l'envoyez aussi les
passages inutiles je le mets antillais
mais aux urgences à une visite chez le
médecin généraliste encore faut-il
trouver un médecin généraliste en cette
saison et deuxièmement le conseil
scientifique avait expliqué que seuls
les masques ffp2 été efficace contre les
sous variantes ou année l'information la
fabrication et la mise à disposition de
ces masses est pour le grand public et
les profils les plus à risque et je
finirai en disant que le coc vide
s'installe durablement dans nos vies
vous traitez le virus seulement en cas
de vague nous en sommes à la septième
est depuis mars 2020 à quand une
stratégie sanitaire globale sur le long
terme je vous remercie merci sénatrice
marie mercier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre si vous permettez chers
confrères je vais commencer par la
conclusion plus personne n'y comprend
rien
j'en veux pour preuve les consultations
avec mes patients qui me demandent un aj
docteur j'ai eu mes trois doses mais
j'ai eu le vide est-ce que je dois avoir
une quatrième dose etc etc un peu perdu
moi aussi j'ai consulté si je puis dire
l'épidémiologiste de mon hôpital alors
bon tu en es où quand ce patient at il
eu le coc vide s moins de trois mois ou
plus trois mois après la dernière
injection dans ce cas là alors attends
on va chercher donc là on sort les
documents 20 29 7 très épais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait une injection est ce que ça
équivaut à une infection ou vice versa
bref j'ai eu l'impression qu'elle était
presque je dis presque aussi perdus que
moi donc monsieur le ministre nous
sommes ici au sénat extrêmement attachés
à la responsabilité et nous sommes
comptables de ce que nous votons ici et
nous vous avons accompagné en votant le
pass vaccinale le pain sanitaire mais je
crois qu'il faut accepter certaines
erreurs il faut absolument ne pas taire
les effets secondaires des vaccins parce
qu'il y en a comme toute molécule
biochimique mans biochimiquement active
et insisté aussi sur la prévention du
coc vide long on ne parle pas assez du
coc vie de long ensuite vous nous avez
dit les patients doivent informer leur
médecin généraliste
il me semble que celle inverse le
problème aussi et lacées que les
médecins généralistes monsieur le
ministre ils ne savent plus faire ils ne
savent pas traiter ce genre d'infections
parce qu'on a tous été un peu perdue et
il faut aussi le dire et l'avouer même
si c'est la septième vague nous allons
aussi nous heurter à ce qu'on appelle
entre nous l'acceptabilité du traitement
si on n'est pas suffisamment clair pas
suffisamment transparent nos passions ne
vont plus nous suivre d'où qu'il faut là
encore et ça c'est un
quelque chose qu'il faut que vous ayez
en tête c'est rétablir la confiance
notre pays est fracturée les français
sont un peu perdus dans tout il faut
rétablir absolument la confiance pour
qu'ils nous croient qu'il croit le
gouvernement qu'il vous crois vous qui
croie les parlementaires qui croient
leur médecin de façon à ce que ensemble
nous arrivions à juguler cette pandémie
qui probablement en inaugurera d'autres
même si en général je suis plutôt
optimiste
donc c'est ce que je vous demande
monsieur le ministre instamment
transparence et clarifications
sur le compte
il merci monsieur le ministre
ce que vous pouvez nous faire un point
sur les stocks et l'actualisation des
vaccins dans la mesure où bon pour
l'instant quatrième dose a été ouverte
aux plus de 60 ans mais vous pouvez
avoir des gens qui considèrent que ce
serait bien de se protéger avec une
quatrième dose alors qu'ils n'ont pas 60
ans et d'autre part des personnes qui
veulent voyager dans des pays où on leur
demande un booster de moins de six mois
donc est ce qu'on peut avoir un point
sur sa et en même temps sur les
perspectives de l'actualisation des
vaccins et deuxièmement bon même si
l'article 2 n'a pas été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale il il prévoyait et
c'est heureux que le décret qui
décrivait les choses en particulier les
justificatifs de statut vaccinal soit
pris après avis de la haute autorité de
santé c'était ça faisait partie des
amendements que j'avais défendu
auparavant donc c'est une avancée mais
ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer que
s'il revenait
vous veillerez à ce que le parcours
vaccinale soit qui prennent en compte
les personnes qui ont été vaccinées à
l'étranger et soit un parcours vaccinale
et ce qui est une perspective de définir
un parcours vaccinale au niveau européen
c'est à dire aussi la manière de traiter
des vaccins qui n'ont pas été reconnues
par là la m e mais qui sont utilisés
dans un certain nombre de pays européens
de manière à ce qu'il n'y ait pas voilà
des divergences de statut vaccinaux qui
pose problème au moment des
reconnaissances de vaccins je veux si
ces notes reçues par l'anguille
benarroch
sur l'arrêt sport
voulez vous remercie
sur la responsabilisation individuelle
et collective sur le nécessité dû vivre
avec ce virus et les suivants dans les
temps à venir et sur la priorisation
vous avez semblé pointé
concernant la transparence de vos
actions
en ce qui concerne cette transparence de
vos actions une petite question
par le passé nous nous sommes plaints
souvent de ne pas recevoir de manière
concomitante les éléments qui vous avait
été rendue par le conseil scientifique
est ce que vous avez créé
malgré l'existence preuve du
hsc du hcsp donc ma question numéro est
la suivante en fait quand et vous
nous faire parvenir ces éléments de
manière concomitante à celle à laquelle
vous l'obtenez vous même concernant les
dispositifs de surveillance de grande
ampleur je rejoindrai tout à fait mon
collègue loïc avait
cela fait maintenant longtemps qu'ils
sont mais tu lui et qu'ils peuvent être
consultées par public finalement assez
large
d'où les avis de la cnil d'ailleurs
successifs
donc je voulais insister sur le fait
qu'il fallait absolument
veiller à ce que ces outils de traçage
ray strictement limitée dans le temps et
que nous puissions être consultées
régulièrement si vous souhaitez les
projets concernant enfin les différentes
mesures dont vous avez parlé
de telle façon à prévenir les épidémies
à protéger la population je
conçois effectivement que vous puissiez
annoncé ces mesures je me permet quand
même de dire que
rien de précis sur les masques alors non
seulement sur le port des masques mais
aussi par exemple sur la mise à
disposition des masques ffp2
gratuitement
pas grand chose
de nouveau dans les vaccins avec un flou
comme là
expliquer ma collègue marie mercier et
en particulier qu'en est il des autres
vaccins des vaccins différents qui sont
pas ceux qui ont été mis sur le marché
et promos et promulguée jusqu'à présent
et toujours pour la protection
je rejoins aussi la question qui
consiste à dire que feu que faisons-nous
quel est votre doctrine vis-à-vis du
personnel - soignants de leur obligation
vaccinale ou pas prolongé et de la
réintégration possible dans la situation
aujourd'hui de la santé des hôpitaux en
france 2 des soignants qui ont été
suspendus
merci ce sénateur monsieur alain richard
ensuite madame de la gontrie puis madame
assassine
suisse je fais suite à la
passage de l'avis du conseil d'état qui
relève ce qui est objectif que les
dispositions du code de la santé
publique
qui permettent la mise en jeu de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire par décret confirmée
par une loi au bout d'un mois
subsistent dans la législation même s'il
n'en est plus fait usage à partir de
l'ue 31 juillet et le conseille
d'ailleurs ce livre une critique que je
ne partage pas forcément qui consiste à
dire que ce dispositif n'a pas son
équilibre et qu' il ne serait pas
forcément
adapté dans le cas de nouvelle de
nouvelles crises sanitaires donc je
voulais vous demander si évidemment pas
la mi-juillet mais si dans les semaines
qui suivent le gouvernement entend et en
s'entourant bien entendu des
consultations utiles peut-être même
celle de parlementaires
de se prononcer sur cette question de ce
qu'on maintient en vigueur disponible à
tout moment dans le code de santé
publique pour faire face à l'urgence
sanitaire en tenant compte de
l'expérience
merci monsieur sénateurs mam de la
contrée
merci président
bienvenue monsieur le ministre dans une
assemblée où vous l'avez noté les débats
peuvent être très exigeant mais toujours
très courtois trois questions la
première c'est que je confesse ne pas
avoir extrêmement bien compris vos
réponses concernant les pouvoirs de
police générale de la première ministre
et au fond que se passerait-il s'il n'y
avait pas de texte était alité rappelons
que la première loi qui a été votée est
une loi du 23 mars 2020 et que le
premier confinement était du 17 mars
mais peut-être que les circonstances
faisait que personne ne s'y opposer mais
juridiquement on voit bien qu'il ya donc
voilà première question deuxième
question
sans vous donner mon point de vue celui
de mon groupe vous avez tenu des propos
semble t-il comment dire ouverts à la
discussion enfin bon sur la question
dite de la réintégration des soignants
donc indépendamment de notre point de
vue est ce que vous pouvez préciser
comment vous envisager les choses et
troisième chose
concernant la variole du singe
il semble que là aussi nous ayons une
certaine lenteur
en france dans la façon dont était
appréhendé ce sujet
j'ai noté que dès le 20 mai la haute
autorité de santé préconise est une
stratégie vaccinale et qu'il a fallu
attendre le 5 juillet est un mois et
demi pour l'ouverture des premiers
centres de vaccination qu'en est-il sur
7 sur cette maladie comment
appréhendez-vous les choses et comment
entendez vous faire face à cette
possible épidémie merci monsieur minutes
merci même massé la crise alors madame
assassi qui est en visioconférence comme
la présidente
je vous entends parfaitement j'allais
vous posez la question tout va bien et
je suis ravi bonjour monsieur le
président bonjour mes chers collègues
bonjour monsieur le ministre est
bienvenu dans cette haute assemblée
pleine de sagesse donc monsieur le
ministre je veux bien entendre un
certain nombre de vos propos mais ne
sont quand même qu'il ya quelques trous
dans la raquette si je peux me permettez
l'expression
s'agit s'agissant particulièrement des
hôpitaux pouvez vous nous dire
précisément comment vont fonctionner nos
hôpitaux face à cette nouvelle vague et
puis l'été venu avec un surplus si je
puis dire de population notamment le
nombre de touristes qui viennent forte
heureusement visiter d'autres pays
donc comment quelles mesures
comptez-vous prendre et notamment allez
vous la question a déjà été posée mais
allez-vous se
décider de la reprise de l'activité des
soignants qui ne sont pas vaccinés et je
voulais savoir si vous allez maintenir
les conclusions de votre mission flash
sur les fermetures notamment des
urgences sur la vaccination
là aussi la question était posée donc je
suis redondantes ou en étant précisément
sur la quatrième dose et ses modalités
mêmes questions que monsieur benarroch
s'agissant des mesures de protection et
particulièrement sur les masques et là
encore particulièrement sur les masques
ffp2 je remercie la présidente alors
encore les deux dernières questions
monsieur hussein bourgi n'évacue kerma
d'après on est sur la parole au ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je voudrais
prolonger la question de notre collègue
marie pierre de la gontrie sur la
variole du singe monsieur le ministre le
8 juillet dernier la haute autorité de
santé a préconisé l'extension de la
vaccination préventive à des populations
dites à risque
l'ong juillet dernier le gouvernement a
recommandé à ses services déconcentrés
les ars en particulier de mettre en
oeuvre cette préconisation
hélas mille fois hélas depuis le 11
juillet les associations d'usagers qui
ont une expertise en la matière peine à
trouver des créneaux disponibles sur les
différentes plateformes dédiées à la
vaccination à la prise de rendez vous
pour la vaccination on me dit que mes
peut-être vous allez le démentir qu'il
n'y aurait eu que 40 doses de vaccin
pour l'hôpital saint louis à paris et qu
elles auraient toutes été réservées à
des personnes contaminées par cette
maladie aucune information des ars ne ce
qui semble complètement dépassé par les
événements il se trouve que j'ai écris
moi même au directeur régional de la rs
d'occitanie puisque je suis sénateur de
l'hérault puisque j'avais été sollicité
par les organisations professionnelles
de praticiens hospitaliers les
associations d'usagers ça fait quinze
jours je n'ai toujours pas reçu de
réponse de sa part et que me disaient
ces praticiens six organisations
professionnelles d'hospitaliers et ses
associations d'usagers
la rs a confié la mission à l'hôpital
public de prendre en charge les
personnes contaminées se réservant le
droit de contacter les personnes
contacts afin de les vacciner or il
apparaît que dans mon département dans
ma région à la région occitanie aucune
personne qu'à contacter n'ai été
contacté par l'ats m la rs en vue d'une
vaccination préventive donc mes
questions sont toutes simples de combien
de doses de vaccins disposons nous
aujourd'hui pour la france pourquoi la
france a refusé de bénéficier des lots
de vaccins qui ont été proposées à
l'échelle européenne et que pouvez vous
nous dire aujourd'hui factuellement sur
la mise en oeuvre des préconisations que
vous avez formulé qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire auprès des services
déconcentrés pour que vos instructions
soient mises en oeuvre avec beaucoup de
diligence je vous remercie monsieur
ministre
oui merci à monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre au préalable dire
que je fais partie de ceux qui ont
toujours défendu le recours au vaccin
pour combattre cette pandémie cependant
il sans rouvrir ici les débats nous
savons il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont reste aujourd'hui en
tout cas on retrait la question a
beaucoup été porté hier à son
nationalisme attendant certaines
interventions de mes collègues sur les
personnels soignants qui en l'état
aujourd'hui ne sont pas vaccinés ou ne
remplissent pas en tout cas une
obligation vaccinale complète il y a
également aujourd'hui dans nos
départements la question qui est posée
par les sapeurs pompiers volontaires ou
professionnels qui sont aujourd'hui des
personnes fortement mobilisés mobilisés
en renfort sur d'autres départements par
rapport à des problématiques d'un
incendie de feux de forêt mais aussi
nous l'avons malheureusement vécu dans
notre région auvergne rhône-alpes
par de nombreux épisodes de grêle qui
ont nécessité
les interventions des sapeurs pompiers
nous avons dans un certain nombre de
casernes aujourd'hui des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires qui ont été
suspendus qui ne comprennent pas dès
lors que l'obligation du pas salutaire a
été
relevée dans notre pays et donc de fait
des sapeurs pompiers en intervention qui
peut être certes ont été vaccinées mais
sont porteurs de duke au vide sous une
nouvelle forme eux qui reste en retrait
et en tout cas des femmes et des hommes
qui manquaient à l'appel pour secourir
nos populations dans les départements où
venir en appui dans d'autres
départements pour combattre les
différentes difficultés et
malheureusement vu l'été que l'on nous
annonce je crains que ces épisodes se
renouvelle et plus que des sapeurs
pompiers qui viennent en renfort dans
d'autres départements dans tous nos
départements nous aurons besoin d'avoir
l'ensemble des professionnels et
volontaires
de des sapeurs pompiers qui seront
nécessaires pour satisfaire à la
sécurité urgente en tout cas de nos
populations jour l'air si c'est la crise
est bien
terminé monsieur le ministre la série
des questions maintenant nous attendons
vos réponses v la parole
merci monsieur le président en
question sont nombreuses et je suis
vraiment ravi de cette discussion autour
pardon de l'ensemble de ces sujets je
vous prie d'abord de bien vouloir
m'excuser si j'oublie quelques réponses
parce qu'il y avait vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de questions mais bien entendu
je me tiens à votre disposition pour
pour compléter s'il a été nécessaire
préalablement monsieur le rapporteur une
petite précision juridique sur l'article
2 comme vous le souhaitiez le pouvoir
propre de la première ministre peut être
utilisée aussi sur les frontières mais
dans le but de les fermer de bloquer les
frontières d'interdire les déplacements
pas d'exiger le pass ça semble un peu
paradoxal en gros c'est la massue pour
tuer la mouche mais en tout cas c'est
c'est le cas c'est un peu à part à ne
pas s' législatives qui permet de se
distinguer un petit peu tout ça c'est
plutôt un certain sens la loi cette
possibilité d'exiger le pass c'est à
dire qu'on risque de devoir utiliser des
mesures un peu trop un peu trop
importante et concernant l'article de
bien entendu nous sommes totalement
disponible et je suis totalement
disponible pour bâtir avec vous une
nouvelle rédaction de cet article qui
prendrait en compte les différentes
remarques mais qui qui permettrait comme
je le disais tout à l'heure de nous
laisser quand même moins parachute
ventrale pour ce saut depuis l'avion
alors j'ai reprendre un petit peu les
différents
les différents éléments
concernant le bilan le bilan des mesures
et ce qui a été fait je crois
qu'effectivement l'article 3 va nous
permettre de répondre d'ailleurs le
parlement a souhaité cumuler ces deux
articles articles 3 et l'article 4 dans
le cadre d'un rapport d'évaluation sur
le bilan d'ensemble des mesures par
rapport à cette crise et je reviendrai
devant vous si vous le souhaitez pour
présenter ce rapport vraiment en toute
transparence comme cela a toujours été
mon cas sur l'ensemble des sujets
la question des soignants suspendu pas à
jour est effectivement une question une
question compliquée
il y aurait il y aurait malheureusement
je ne peux pas avoir de chiffres précis
à un prêt même à 10 près de ré environ
12 mille professionnels de santé
concernés c'est d'ailleurs ce ne sont
pas que des soignants le chiffre qui m'a
été fournie par la fédération
hospitalière de france dit que sur les
deux cent soixante trois mille
infirmières de service public
hospitalier il y en a moins de 500 qui
sont concernés par cette part cette
suspension
globalement c'est à peu près 0,4 pour
cent de l'ensemble des ionel de santé et
là je rends hommage ou 99 6% qui sont
vaccinées dans une logique de protection
individuelle bien sûr mais surtout dans
une logique de protection collective non
seulement pour protéger notre système de
santé mais aussi pour pouvoir rester au
front et j'ai vu tous ses collègues
restés au front pendant ces premières
vagues alors concernant ce sujet épineux
je me suis engagé à saisir dans les
jours qui viennent les autorités de
santé la has le conseil consultatif
national d'éthique sur cette question
particulière nous avons toujours pendant
cette pandémie suivi l'avis des
scientifiques et nous continuerons à
suivre l'avis des scientifiques
une fois ces avis récupérer je réunirai
les syndicats de personnels soignants
pour leur présenter ses avis et avoir
une discussion là aussi transparente
avec eux que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités non pas sur des idées
mais sur des arguments scientifiques
précis
en ce qui concerne les urgences jeu
peut-être continuer là je reviendrai
après sur la question des urgences
alors sur les sur les ffp2 versus masque
chirurgical le masque chirurgical vous
savez être un masque anti projections
qui évite à une personne contaminée de
projeter le virus vers les autres il est
arrêté par cette barrière le masque ffp2
et lui un masque de protection c'est à
dire qu'ils évitent la projection mais
il évite aussi l'inspiration d'un virus
qui serait aérosols is est dans l'air
encore faut-il qu'ils soient bien porter
bien ajustées ce fameux fidh test vous
savez on doit aspirer et on a comme une
tête de canard donc il faut bien le
vérifier
c'est pas facile à supporter j'en ai
l'expérience quand il faut le garder
quatre heures d'affilée le changer bah
c'est pas simple surtout en plus en ce
moment quand il quand il fait chaud
deux masques chirurgicaux face à face
offre un niveau de protection important
puisque tous les deux évite de projeter
donc on revient un petit peu un petit
peu à la même chose par contre je crois
qu'il faut être là clair ce âge du
masque pour les personnes fragiles il
faut conseiller plutôt le port du ffp2
est toujours conseillé le port d'un
masque chirurgical en face de ces
personnes
les doses de vaccin personne n'y
comprend plus rien je suis pas loin de
vous rejoindre
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué entre les
doses entre est ce qu'on a été malade
est ce qu'on n'a pas été malade et cela
témoigne vraiment de l'humilité je le
disais qu'on doit avoir face à cette
pandémie on n'a pas connu vous savez
comme moi de pandémie de ce type depuis
plus d'une centaine d'années on re
découvre aussi avec nos moyens de
transport avec toute notre façon de
travailler il ya toujours cette notion
de rapport bénéfice/risque un la
vaccination permet quand même d'être
beaucoup moins ex créé temps même si on
était contaminé donc ça reste très
efficace
la quatrième dose si on a eu le coc bid
saisi hier de la haute autorité de santé
pour qu'elle se prononce sur
l'équivalence entre infection et
injection dans un contexte de
circulation de ce nouveau variant le bk
de beyssac puisque vous le savez chaque
variant introduit quand même des
subtilités différentes et c'est là aussi
que ça crée tous les problèmes donc très
clairement j'attends très rapidement la
vie de la chaise qui pourra nous dire ou
pas si vous avez été infectés c'est
comme si vous aviez été vaccinés et dans
ce cadre-là de le cadre vaccinale
habituels se met en place vous parlez
également de l'acceptabilité du
traitement c'est pas simple est de
rétablir la confiance je vous suis
totalement sur cette logique nous avons
besoin de rétablir la confiance mais pas
seulement avec les soigner comme je
disais tout à l'heure mais aussi et
surtout avec les soignants les meilleurs
relais de l'information les meilleurs
partenaires pour protéger notre
population ce sont les soignants et nous
avons besoin de rétablir la confiance
avec eux dans la transparence dans la
clarification ans est en tout cas toute
la la base la base de ma politique
stocks de vaccins
vous vouliez des précisions je vais
essayer de vous les donner le plus
possible les injections déjà réalisé en
première injection 54
millions
53 26 ans 2e 40 points 3e
3,7 en quatrième c'est à dire le
deuxième rappel sur les plus de 60 ans
les personnes fragiles avec une
dynamique ascendante sur le nombre de
vaccinations ce qui concerne les stocks
grosso modo 70 millions de vaccins en
stock donc nous sommes prêts même si il
fallait faire une vaccination plus large
et et vous savez que nous suivons avec
l'europe les commandes de vaccins les
évolutions vers les nouvelles
générations vers les vaccin bivalent
entre guillemets qui tendrait plusieurs
heures plusieurs mutations
sur les dons qu'il y avait une question
sur
la transparence oui donc la saisine du
conseil scientifique ça je voulais dit
les outils de surveillance de grande
ampleur bien sûr hein je le redis c'est
le sait le thermomètre et il faut garder
absolument ce thermomètre le contrôle
par la cnil vous l'avez vous l'avez
souligné dans son 5e à vie la cnil
faisait quelques remarques et elle
remarquer également que le gouvernement
avait suivi ses avis précédents et nous
allons continuer à le faire bien entendu
sur des ajustements nécessaires en ce
qui concerne les délais vous savez que
en cas de en cas de test négatif de
délai de conservation des documents et
de trois mois il est de 6 mois en cas de
test de tests positifs
monsieur richard
réfléchir sur l'avenir des régimes de
crise oui bien sûr c'est tout l'objet
des travaux que nous allons conduire
nous devons avoir un socle un socle
solide pour anticiper les futures crises
et avoir un cadre finalement qui
satisfera nous demande je dirais plus
qu'un cadre c'est à dire que je suis
assez attaché mais ça ça doit être à
cause de mon adn d'urgentistes un
principe que les militaires connaissent
bien et qu'on a appris avec eux lors des
attentats et qu'on applique chaque fois
c'est le principe de la doctrine de la
stratégie et de la tactique
la doctrine c le gouvernement c'est vous
la chambre qui devait définir la
doctrine dans le cadre d'une gestion de
crise doctrine qui était au début de la
crise qu vide vous devez soigner tout le
monde voilà une doctrine claire la
stratégie c'est
le ministère par exemple ce sont les ars
par exemple qui doivent voir comment on
applique cette doctrine en fonction des
circonstances
effectivement cette crise sanitaire
n'est pas la même que la prochaine n'est
pas la même que la précédente
donc il va falloir une adaptation de la
doctrine en fonction des situations et
puis la tactique tactique il faut la
laisser sur le terrain une fois qu'on a
défini la stratégie des sons et faisons
confiance aux organisations de terrain
pour la mettre en place c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé pendant la première
vague qui nous a permis depuis les seuls
de la france de mettre en place des
transferts par tgv qui nous a permis de
mettre en place des ponts aériens avec
nos outre-mer
donc bien sûr dans le cadre du rapport
d'évaluation ce principe de doctrine de
stratégie et de tactique sera repris
pour que nous ayons une vision
prospective
ces trois mois
on va avoir un été bien occupé
concernant le monkey pox effectivement
préoccupations actuelles
de mes services et moi même aujourd'hui
912 cas confirmés dans une grande
majorité de cas en ile-de-france
569 cas en ile-de-france
à peu près un petit peu plus de 700
vaccination de cas contacts aujourd'hui
vous avez parlé des recommandations de
la has qui sont sorties vendredi dernier
si mes souvenirs sont bons dès l'après
midi
non les recommandations sur la
vaccination préventive pardon
recommandations sur la vaccination
préventive qui est le cas qui nous
préoccupe un principalement maintenant
sur la vaccination préventive donc
vendredi dernier j'ai immédiatement
saisi des ars qui avait été préméditée
bien entendu sur 7 sur cette
préoccupation
à partir de lundi début de semaine les
centres de vaccination sont mises en
place 70 centres de vaccination
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
une mise à disposition de vaccin
largement suffisante mais vous le savez
comme moi c'est vaccination font partie
d'un stock d'état menace taux qui est
couvert par le secret défense pour des
raisons liées à la problématique de la
variole comme armes chimiques mais en
tout cas je vous garantis que nous avons
un nombre suffisant de vaccins j'ai
entendu des préoccupations locales et
des soucis avec certaines ars et je vais
revenir vers eux extrêmement rapidement
c'est à dire de cet après midi pour
savoir ce qui se passe en tout cas je
leur ai donné les moyens de prendre en
charge l'ensemble de cette problématique
sûr mais pas sur l'actionner sion
préventive ainsi je peux me permettre
d'insister
je vais vérifier cela je voulais dit dès
cet après-midi en tout cas les ars ont
été mobilisés par moi-même dès vendredi
après midi pour mettre en place cette
vaccination
concernant la situation
des hôpitaux
plus globalement la situation de notre
système de santé vous le savez on parle
de crise d urgence mais les urgences se
sont que la partie émergée de l'iceberg
c'est la résultante de difficultés de
l'hôpital de difficultés de de la ville
et c'est dans ce cadre là que ma
prédécesseure
avait confié une mission avec
effectivement quarante et une mesure et
ses 40 mais une mesure ont été reprises
et est validée par la première ministre
aboutissants moins d'une semaine après
une semaine après à une instruction que
j'ai envoyée aux ars pour reprendre et
leur donner les outils pour
essayer avec ce qui se fait déjà dans un
certain nombre de territoires puisque
c'était ça l'essence même de cette
mission c'était d'aller voir ce qui se
fait dans les territoires de l'analyser
et de donner ce même outil à tout le
monde donc la possibilité de mettre un
certain nombre de mesures en place
premier point il n'est pas question de
fermeture comme j'ai pu l'entendre des
services d'urgence de nos concitoyens
qui trouve une porte close en tout cas
cela ne fait pas partie des
recommandations cela ne fait pas partie
des mesures ce qui en fait partie c'est
la possibilité d'offrir à nos
concitoyens des parcours de santé plus
adapté à leurs problèmes que devenir
systématiquement aux urgences si vous
avez mal au genou depuis trois semaines
c'est pas en allant à tant de six heures
dans les services d'urgences que vous
serez mieux pris en charge c'est
probablement en allant voir votre
médecin traitant voire en allant voir un
médecin qui est peut-être à deux rues de
chez vous et qui dispose d'un créneau
qui l'a mis à disposition pour prendre
ses soins non programmés alors on parle
de triage la notion de triage est très
mal vu et très mal comprise et ça je
l'entends bien je parle plutôt de
qualification de la demande c'est
typiquement ce que nous faisons dans le
cadre de la médecine d'urgence
c'est-à-dire que quand quelqu'un a un
symptôme bien notre préoccupation est de
savoir quel est le meilleur parcours de
soin pour ce symptôme si vous avez mal
dans la poitrine ça peut être une crise
d'angoissé où ça peut être un infarctus
la prise en charge ne va pas être la
même on le comprend bien
artus vous allez être pris en charge
immédiatement sur un plateau de
coronarographie la crise d'angoissé vous
pouvez pris en charge par un conseil
médical et en allant voir votre médecin
traitant c'est le travail qui est fait
au niveau des samu centre 15 au niveau
de cette régulation médicale ce travail
qui évolue avec l'intégration de nos
confrères généralistes dans la
régulation médicale au sein du service
d'accès aux soins et c'est repartir vers
ce service d'accès aux soins commencer
par ce service d'accès aux soins avant
de vous déplacer appelé est un des
messages importants pourquoi appeler bat
pas pour vous empêcher d'accéder aux
soins loin de là mais bien pour vous
fournir le meilleur parcours de soins
possibles nous pourrons revenir sur
cette problématique je pense que nous
aurons l'occasion pour les premiers
résultats sur les 22 sites pilotes du
saas montrent leur efficacité sur les
délais de réponse la rapidité de réponse
en moins de 30 secondes commençons à
atteindre les meilleurs standards
internationaux personne n'atteint
actuellement france
et puis sur l'efficience de ce
dispositif
donc pas de fermeture ça c'est clair
mais surtout ce résultat de cette
mission flash sont pour moi mettre sur
la table la façon dont j'ai envie de
fonctionner c'est à dire le principe
d'aller chercher des idées sur les
territoires parce que c'est depuis les
territoires qu on a les bonnes idées et
les déplacements que j'ai pu faire en
particulier en côte d'or montré une
dynamique de territoire sur
l'organisation de ces maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelle qui en plus
attirent des jeunes donc on voit bien
que ces cdi des locales il y en a
d'autres qui vont nous permettre de
construire quelque part transformer
l'essai avec ses idées local pour les
mettre les transformer en outils et
mettre à disposition du territoire cette
boîte à outils c'est en tout cas comme
ça que je veux fonctionner pourquoi
parce que
la problématique de désert médical ou
quel que soit le terme qu'on lui donne
n'est pas la même dans l'est de la
moselle que je connais bien les
pathologies ne sont pas les mêmes que
dans le pays basque ou que dans qu'en
bretagne c'est donc bien fournir un
ensemble d'outils et revenir vers les
élus et j'insiste beaucoup sur la place
des élus dans ce dispositif on aura
certainement l'occasion à coudre
discuter de la problématique des déserts
médicaux mais avec les élus avec les
soigner nos compatriotes qu'il faut
entendre et avec les soignants que nous
devons construire c'est tout les sens de
la concertation des parties prenantes a
annoncé par le président république et
que je commence à conduire dès cet
après-midi d'ailleurs avec les
représentants des professionnels les
représentants des médecins que ce soit
étudiante que ce soit libéraux que ce
soit hospitalier ensemble pour bien
montrer que nous descendons un petit peu
c'est ces éléments
alors je regarde un petit peu donc
l'occitanie j'en ai parlé
les sapeurs pompiers vous en avait parlé
bien sûr je rends hommage à à
l'application des sapeurs pompiers dans
la gestion de cette crise aux côtés des
soignants personnellement dans mon
département je peux vous dire que le
directeur du sdiss m'a appelé dès le
début de la crise en me disant si ça te
si ça peut aider je mets à ta
disposition des membres de mon service
de santé de secours médical qui vont
venir à la régulation médicale du samu
et qui vont vous aider j'ai dit oui bien
sûr et nous avons travaillé la main dans
la main pendant toute la phase initiale
de cette crise et encore maintenant donc
je rends hommage à ces sapeurs pompiers
dès lors qu'ils entrent dans le cadre du
secours mais également de gestes de
soins d'urgence et vous savez qu'un
décret a été pris en ce sens sont les
mêmes contraintes que les personnels
soignants ce qui semble tout à fait
logique et ma réponse sera identique en
attendant des les différents avis et je
pense avoir fait à peu près le tour
concernant alors monsieur dragon tri
madame barre donc madame madame de la
gontrie excusez moi tant que je vous
reconnaissent les pouvoirs propres de la
première ministre c'est ces deux choses
distinctes les pouvoirs ordinaire c'est
la jurisprudence la bonne ça suffit pour
le masque et des pouvoirs
extraordinaires en cas de circonstances
exceptionnelles
c'est la jurisprudence
rsc d'un cas de mesure plus grave plus
restrictives
voilà comme je les dis je reste à votre
disposition pour discuter de d'éventuels
points de détail comme vous le savez je
cherche pas d'excusés mais j'ai un
conseil des ministres à 10 heures mais
en tout cas on les quelques instants qui
nous reste je suis à votre disposition
si j'ai oublié quelque chose
elle devrait contribuer je me sens très
bien monsieur le ministre merci de la
précision de vos réponses voilà est-ce
que vous êtes fixé un calendrier de
travail dans votre concertation sur la
question des soignants vous avez parlé
de la consultation des autorités
scientifiques puis des syndicats voilà
vous pensez mener ces discussions à
quelle échéance merci monsieur ministre
oui déjà je vous rassure je vais pas
prendre de congés donc je vais être là
bas tout l'été mais la saisie la saisie
des autorités jouer dans les jours qui
viennent donc ça va être là sur cette
fin de semaine dès que j'ai la vie et je
vais demander l'avis le plus rapidement
possible pas vous engager dans un jour 2
jours 3 jours m'ont tout cas dès que
j'ai la vie je réunirai les
représentations syndicales pour leur
présenter ses avis et discuter avec eux
des suites à donner en tous cas très
rapidement et pas avant le délai de
trois mois prévu pour les rapports bien
entendu
merci a été trop questions qui ont déjà
été bien dense
et bien non c'est à vous remercier
monsieur le ministre votre présence ce
matin et a levé la séance de notre
commission sachant que nous reprenons à
10 heures en présence de nos collègues
de la commission des affaires
culturelles et sportives
donc mon mot de la séance est suspendue
nous reprenons à 10 heures toujours ici